Her low freak bitches when people heard about this like,
and you see the headlines and this is another like problem with like click bait
journalism.
The headlines look like I was fucking accused of rape.
There was a one article that used the word sexual harassment.
Sexual misconduct was in all the headlines that I have no fucking idea about.
People connected to Harvey Weinstein,
like about Ben Affleck,
they call it sexual misconduct.
What does that mean?
Like,
but in something that you don't think they should do.
What's really crazy legal and,
and I almost lost a job.
I did just lose a Gig.
Um,
because when you Google and B,
it's like sexual misconduct stuff and like that's really scary.
And again,
I don't want to be like,
you know who the real victim of Harvey Weinstein is?
Jamie Kilstein.
Right.
But like,
uh,
let me just stop you right here.
If you say like one more time,
I fucking head's going to explode too.
And I get comments like that.
It's brutal.
It's a brutal,
is it as bad as all right.
I just want you to slow it down.
I'm going to use it every now and then.
This coffee break,
you're breaking the light.
The light meter.
I'm going to,
I do it too,
man.
A lot of people do it.
It's an easy one to do.
I'm going to hit the switch to water,
but that word is a,
it's an,
um,
it's,
uh,
people use it as,
um,
I know,
I know.
It's okay.
I do it too.
We all do it,
but it's just,
it's nice to know.
Yeah,
no,
I,
it's also a very progressive thing.
Like there's a way like that people talk,
like when they're really progressive that like,
you don't hear like leftwing people talk.
I keep getting fucked over by the progressive's.
It's a way of appearing.
Um,
what's the word?
Submissive or
passive.
Yeah.
It's not a,
it's not an aggressive way of communicating.
All right.
What if I said like,
but like I kept like punching the table,
like as I did it on a fucking,
like how much,
you know,
like go to like step to me,
just smash a paps.
Uh,
can,
um,
so,
so you got a bunch of people that were upset at you because you had embodied the
quintessential allies.
So it was,
there were nobody had a reason to like me or to defend me on one half of the
twittersphere you had progressive's who thought I was a sexual creep.
And then on the other half you have comedy fans who are like,
fuck this dude.
He's the one who called everyone in a sexist.
You don't need to read the article if you see a headline,
I mean God,
I attacked so many people without fucking reading the articles.
Of course there are people to this day that will come up on citizen radio that I
don't know why I was mad at,
I would just figure out the story as we were covering it and be like,
yeah,
fuck that guy.
I guess of course.
And so nobody,
there was no reason to root for me.
There wasn't a strong enough fan base.
It wasn't like if,
you know,
a,
a bigger comic gets accused of something,
well he has thousands or millions of fans and then this small community who are
accused of something I had sort of nobody and when I burnt all the bridges and
in comedy and you know,
I never just showed up at clubs to do sets and stuff like that.
I just had this audience and sort of thought I could never get fired,
you know?
Um,
like when,
when Allie and I sort of became more platonic before the open relationship.
I mean there were days it was,
it was so,
you know,
I mean I would sleep on the couch,
but there were days I would go on the road and I would not cheat and I would go
back to the hotel and sure coffin,
like my orgasm was better.
Cause I'm like,
I saved citizen radio.
Like I was trying so hard not to,
not to do anything like that.
And so anyway,
I lost.
Yeah,
there was no one to root for me.
I just had this small audience.
This small audience either thinks I'm a Predator or they're too nervous to say
anything.
Well you fit the Quintess you,
you,
there's a classic view of what a male feminist is and that classic view is a
sneaky guy that is like getting in tight with women and saying all the things
they really want to hear.
And the classic story is that those women are never attracted to that guy anyway
and one up and go and fuck some jocks.
I'm alpha.
I mean that's literally what happened is like yeah,
you don't say like do you the royalty of is this enormous movie empire,
right.
And we find that particularly offensive that it's not just,
he's not just a creep trying to get laid.
He's a guy that was trying to hold that power over people and use it against
them.
And then on top of it he was like physically forceful.
So you've got like your worst case scenarios and then you have like guys that
are just trying to get laid.
You're like,
okay,
how do you,
what,
what we we demonizing aggressive heterosexuality.
Like where does this go?
Where does this go into sexual assault?
Like rubbing up against someone physically touching them when they don't want
you to?
Well that's sexual assault.
Sure.
But hitting on someone,
right.
Hmm.
That doesn't seem like sexual assault or anything.
It seems like someone just trying to get laid,
like where does it,
but then when someone's the boss he go,
okay,
but then you're not supposed to do that when you're a boss.
Right.
I,
I was,
I was very interested in the,
in the d and the dynamic between what specifically with the Harvey Weinstein and
his people under him for many decades about,
I,
I was trying to put myself in this position of like,
how does this stay quiet for so long?
Even though there's a little rumblings,
like they talk about Seth Mcfarlane's joke at some award show Kevin Spacey to
a little kid was running away from silos with Lockton Kevin Spacey.
Spacement it's,
it's amazing that like this stuff is kind of like an open secret and so,
but still doesn't seep out or really,
um,
it makes you think about the,
the power dynamics and how fearful people are in these positions because it's
easy.
My initial instinct was like,
why didn't anyone say anything?
It was similar to that,
like the bill Cosby thing.
I'm like,
why didn't anyone say anything?
But then you realize people were saying things they were,
they were being given hush money,
they were being shut up.
But these are really,
really bad people.
But I agree with you that it,
you know,
I've never been a,
um,
an aggressive flirt flirter as it were.
I've always been very passive with women cause I never really believed in myself
that much,
all of that.
But
I've,
I've known people that have been very flirtatious and,
and you know,
and all of that.
And I'm like,
I wonder what is the line there now and is it okay to,
to,
to be flirtatious,
to call a woman beautiful at a bar or to do something like that as opposed to,
you know,
kind of if a girl likes you.
That's the thing.
Like,
if you meet a girl at a bar and the girl's like,
Collin is a really cool guy,
God,
I'm so into them and cons,
like,
you're really beautiful.
And she's like,
Oh,
I god,
thank you.
And then next thing you know,
you guys are hanging out or you meet a girl at a bar,
she has nothing.
She doesn't want to have anything to do with you.
She's sober,
you're drinking,
your breath smells,
and you're like,
you're really beautiful and you're like,
oh,
gross,
get the fuck away from me.
You know,
it could be exactly the same attempt,
but the person is just not into you.
Right.
You become a creep.
Exactly.
So,
uh,
I'm,
I don't,
uh,
I don't look at the situation now in 2017 with,
you know,
on college campuses and all of these things as,
as desirable for anyone because of who the,
who the hell knows the rules of the landscape,
you know,
now I think a lot of it just comes down to mutual respect and all of that.
Unless you look at merit and character,
you're fucked.
Like if you're like a,
whether or not you think white people are special and then you should keep them
down or boost them up,
it's both toxic.
I think like when it comes to Rachel Dolezal like,
or her problem is not that she wants to be black and she's not,
her problem is that people give a fuck about what she wants.
Right.
She just didn't have that Lang.
It just didn't like,
imagine her whole world could be exactly the same.
The way she behaves could be exactly the same.
The way she dresses,
her actions,
everything.
If she didn't utter a few words that like,
I'm actually black and people were like,
wait,
what?
And then they go into her history.
No,
no,
no.
You want it to be black,
but you weren't black.
You look right.
We added in pasta and that just quick,
quick,
quick.
It's just eyeballs.
Shaun king,
I mean,
he was a part of black lives matter,
obviously.
He wanted to do good,
obviously he wanted to spread good ideas and help people.
The people that he really identified with,
if those tweets are real and I don't know if they are Hashtag wrong skin and
Hashtag trans racial and all that stuff.
And then that's literally how he felt.
He didn't feel it because he hated those people.
He felt it because he identified with them and they're more attractive to him
then the than what he actually was.
So if he just Paul Walden and never said,
I mean Paul Wall,
right?
The,
the wrapper with the grill.
I mean,
isn't that essentially he's lived a deep love of,
of black American culture.
Right.
And there's a lot of people that just,
just be themselves and go in,
go in is what I appreciate more.
There's a lot of black people at golf clubs with fucking Polo shirts on,
right?
Yeah.
Why?
Because they identify with that culture.
It's appealing to them.
What?
Just let people,
fucking cultures everything man.
That people,
Neil.
Whoa.
And the irony is is like Joey Diaz,
he's going to get us grills.
You heard about that.
And the irony is,
is like inner city black culture,
like
things like comes to my shows and thinks I'm funny.
Yeah.
Because they liked that crazy shit.
Like,
man,
you're fucking funny.
You free to talk about things,
right.
They just think it's funny.
I,
I think,
uh,
when I say they,
it's annoying because it's like,
of course not all black people find me funny.
But like that culture,
that black redneck,
white liberal culture,
it's like I'm from a culture that's more similar to American southerner,
urban black culture than a lot of the liberals calling me names.
And it's just this type of culture that that bonds through shit talking,
you know,
like Boston where it's like,
if you talk shit,
if someone's like,
oh,
you're dead,
you're dead.
Acts like a home on I grease.
My Dad's didn't kill himself.
You know,
and then your friends,
Huh?
Cause it's like you've hit the darkest shit,
right.
And then you're like,
oh,
we'll make it through a winter.
Yeah.
Okay.